it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes hoot-hoot where my owls at and
welcome to movie bytes oh yeah you know
you know all the movie fights fans are
referred to as owl nation all right what
an exciting day
the champs in the house the belt is not
on the line and a lot of crap is about
to go down it's movie fights and let's
see who's competing that's right I said
the champs in the house here he is his
first time back in the studio since the
big women in film event cucumber he's a
felted friend cucumber welcome back to
the party how you feeling all ready to
do battle well I'm ready to destroy ya
nice cucumber ah what's a favorite movie
you've seen lately lately yeah I can't
afford movies anymore I didn't let movie
pass thing let's see movies anymore
either
well cucumber damn glad to have you back
in the house once again this is just
just an exhibition the belt is not on
the line but you will be defending it
soon correct correct alright looking
forward to that oh this gentleman you
know him you love them honest trailers
SJ news all that good stuff the super
funny Joe star in the house sir thank
Joe what's going on brother I'm just I'm
excited to be here getting ready to get
completely steamrolled by these two and
yeah it's gonna be a good show it's
gonna be a fun one oh that sounds to me
like he's a glory man yeah sounds to me
that's some classic Joe star playing
possum again throw me in the briar patch
and then BOOM falls back into the
bracket Joe always great to have ya
and oh she has been killing it lately
she's all over the place she's a great
friend of the show she was down at
comic-con with us all that good stuff
welcome back Erica Ishi
good to be back thanks Lydia bye buddy
Joe my buddy how and at my new buddy
cucumber and a friend hey Erica this is
this your first time back in the studio
since you won our WonderCon movie fight
oh my gosh uh no I was at the women in
film event yes yes I I was absolutely
just decimated by Emma Pfeiffer that was
to be expected she is the reigning anime
champ but I think that I'm here to put
in a good showing I have lots of
opinions on the things that we're
talking about today so so let's get to
it so and you have comments all over
your dress
cami it's all it's all like marble it's
all cool marble stone figures yeah super
awesome Erica great to have you as per
usual and we got holding it down over
there it's the Dan camp
Dan Morelle Daniel Radford Dan merle
what's going on buddy how are ya let me
ask you a question how is crazy rich
Asians gonna do at the box office this
weekend I want your box office
prognostication box office
prognostication wall had a good opening
day someone hang on Wednesday house
Friday yeah so you're gonna look at the
five-day but it opened well had a good
first day so I'm gonna predict that it's
gonna it's gonna come in at or exceeding
expectations
nice I'm excited to check that flick out
Dan thank you sir holding it down on the
facts etc Danielle Radford you are the
voice of the people so real quick Dan
every for every argument in the first
three questions dan and I will weigh in
with our opinions and then Danielle will
channel the people's votes and reveal
them to us join us explain a little more
about that please yes so while there are
several very fun polls on Twitter and we
do encourage you to go in there and have
discussion there because I will be
reading some of the things off of
Twitter as well the polls that count is
the poll that is on YouTube if you have
any questions about how to how that
works just go ahead and go into the
description box or you can ask anybody
in the chat and so we will read that
poll for every for every round except
for when we get into the speed rounds
but it only
counts as a tiebreaker but yes please
continue to vote I will be reading those
off and yes please could participate on
the movie fights live hashtag because
I'll be looking for any kind of fun
answers dank memes as I've been here
often says and any of that stuff so
Daniel I thank you yeah welcome sir
alright so again how it works we have
three fighters they will be answering
three regular four of questions before
we get to the speed round the top two
scorers from there will enter the speed
round and the first fighter to achieve
four answers that go their way walks out
of here that the winner today and again
this bad boy is not on the line you know
what I think we're ready for fun jte
talk that's a guest package
[Music]
I snap my fingers and the belt
disappeared in fact felted friend land
okay here's our first question what
we're gonna answer this question today
this is a big one this is a classic all
right it's been a big week for the
Hollywood Chris's Pratt Evans Hemsworth
infinity war hit blu-ray pine and
Hemsworth have walked away from Star
Trek for kookie let's settle this once
and for all
best Hollywood Chris who's the best
Hollywood Chris the answer might shock
you like they say in clickbait uh
cucumber your player number one you go
first
all right Chris Pratt he is the everyman
we should all aspire to be he does not
seek perfection but you know acceptance
of yourself he has those nine rules that
he lives by which you can look up
they're very sweet very inspiring uh you
know he's just he's everything I've ever
wanted to be like I don't ever want to
be like super ejected subtract the hell
I want to be uh somebody that everybody
wants to go have a beer with and that
that's that's Chris Pratt he's adorable
all right cucumber votes Chris Pratt Joe
star I don't understand why we're
talking about this it's Chris Pine it's
Chris Pine is the best Hollywood Chris
he might not be your favorite Hollywood
Chris because all you watches Marvel
movies and Jurassic Park movies but out
of this hole punch Chris goddamn pine is
the most talented most well-rounded
gentleman in this field of Chris's Chris
Pine all right and Joe's mine pine is
fine
Erica Ishii would you take a moment and
say that we are living in a golden age
of Chris's this is probably gonna be
looking back upon after you notice
king's ransom I would like to say that
Chris Hemsworth has no business being as
funny and talented as he is and that
attractive he is probably debatably I
would say the best Twitter Chris he
could because just his bromance with so
many other both the different Chris's
and Ryan Reynolds and take a white TC
you know they're just delightful to
watch also he does a lot of great
charity work he is the ambassador for
the Australian children's no oz
Australian childhood foundation and he
champions a cause that is very close to
my heart and should be closer hearts of
everybody here the motion picture
television fund which provides health
services for people in the motion
picture industry a lot of whom are below
the line and cannot afford it otherwise
alright so Erica is she comin strong for
Chris Hemsworth the better of the
Hemsworth brothers debatable Golden Age
of Hemsworth brothers true ok Before we
jump into this ah no Chris Evans no
start common start commenting now if you
want also chris noth mr. big and Chris
Rock and Kris Kristofferson all right we
have Pratt pine and Hemsworth that's
what's on the table fight it out I just
want to go ahead and start this off with
saying did you know if you just said
Chris Evans and Eric was like oh it was
so hard to choose no it's not hard to
choose it's Chris Pine if you think
there is no ambiguity in this question
don't you are diluting yours there's
absolute here ok there are a lot of
things that connect all these Chris's
they're all very handsome they're all
people I would be very willing to
explore my sexuality with they're all
pretty talented they're all blonde I
think they all do cool charity work and
work for their community let's look at
what separates these Chris's and the big
separator in what makes a Hollywood
Chris is talent and Chris Pine is just
heads and tails more talented than these
guys you're right he's the best at
impersonating a wax figure
and after with the range of the least
creepy guy at the frat party let's calm
down about Chris Pratt just a little bit
cuz Chris Pratt sucks he sucks so bad
Chris Pratt is good at star-lord again
the least threatening guy at the frat
party anytime he's ever tried to do
something other than Andy Dwyer slash
star-lord who are the same character
bright Abbott all family all of his
characters are just not good people
talking Pratt not yeah they're not
they're not great and you know I he
seems like a real nice guy but also the
image of him being like an ordinary man
that drinks beer you cannot have a
six-pack like that and drink beer or eat
anything other than chicken and broccoli
like a six-pack on your body like you
can have like a real city yeah and drink
like that but now he's sold out is what
I'm saying it's coming back it's coming
back he's just like Chris Pratt she's
like Magnificent 7 he's so bad Jurassic
world he's so bad and Chris Hemsworth
great he's 4 I'm sorry the best part of
Ghostbusters and you know a crumpled
piece of paper on the floor could have
been the best but he was he is Bruins
was fantastic in it and then also just
honestly like have you seen the videos
of him like when what for for the
outtakes like Thunder cracks in the sky
during a take any layup
sorry that was me cuz he's just so damn
charming Oh charming pine like I mean I
feel like when I go and not hurt on you
because it's just not he's not in the
same category as the other Chris's how
look the guy does drama he's amazing in
hell and high water he's incredible lead
as Captain Kirk
he's a song-and-dance guy he's amazing
and into the woods he's hilarious Angie
Tribeca wet hot American summer he's
hilarious and very like he plays that
self parody of himself in Horrible
Bosses 2 so well he really does it all
Chris not like in movie necessarily
Chris I mean words wait so is the
argument who's just like your best
neighbor named Chris and the Hollywood
zip code
you bring it you're on camera yeah this
is the most real here though it's not
being in Hollywood right now is not just
about being on camera it's what you
bring to the smaller screen but people
are texting on I'd like to put a pin in
it for a second cucumber we I would love
to hear a little bit more from you yeah
you've had some good singers in there
but what is your argument at that really
lays the groundwork for Pratt being the
best Chris he has more range and people
give him credit for it I think
especially I didn't bring up right
Abbott I know he was young way young
when that started he was on Everwood he
played he played against type a little
bit you know he played a football player
but he's a really sweet kind of kind of
awkward guy who was trying to go put on
this this this kind of tougher facade
you saw him grow completely between
seasons 1 and 3
yes I watched a lot of Everwood and he
as quick as I'll get out that that fella
can come up with a with with a little
quips and and one my improv II things
like nobody's business he's he's super
talented yeah I always believed him no
matter what he's doing with that little
cheesy look on his face it makes me so
happy you know you know I like about
look all these guys have great blooper
reels look I'm up on YouTube they're all
hilarious oh these guys flub a line like
nobody's business what I like about pine
is that sure Kurtz is only like big
that's his one like starring role but
what I like about pine is even in his
what he's able to do with his supporting
roles Steve Trevor is such a cool role
and the thing that I really like about
Chris Pines performance as Steve Trevor
is every choice he makes on camera is to
put over his lead it's to support her
make her look good make her make
everything she plays off him he's just
giving and giving and giving that's
another thing I really like about about
that there Chris Pine he's just a funny
well-rounded dude I understand everybody
has great Twitter's they all have great
PR people working for him well done
Hemsworth hired a great kid in college
to read some funny tweets form
congratulations but on camera which is
what makes a Hollywood Chris it's Chris
Pine
it's Chris Pine you guys you know it in
your heart you know it's true ishii
Hemsworth he's just overall I mean he's
got everything
that we have talked about all these
Chris's having he doesn't have
everything just got you liked IKEA which
I get cuz I can't you're right he chose
to work with in Berlin you think Tyco
ytz would have chosen to do a Marvel
movie if it weren't for Chris Hemsworth
is just watching him work is so great
yes like Chris Pine does a good job of
supporting but Chris Hemsworth is really
a standout in any film he's in and he's
been in a lot of bad films and he's had
to work with a lot of really mediocre
writing and he just runs away with it
and which he took three movies to figure
out that's the thing I've ever seen I've
never seen him really elevate bad
material like I didn't walk out of Snow
White and the Huntsman like holy hell
that Chris Hemsworth is a living God I
walked out of that going that poor son
of a [ __ ] I wish they'd put Liam in
that I really wish they'd have just
given that bullet to Liam Hemsworth no
for sure
Huntsman and Ghostbusters in black hat
you know they're all sort of forgettable
movies but he's great and all of them he
is but pine is pine is is great in a lot
of movies that are memorable and their
memorable largely in part because he's
really fantastic you know they are
definitely memorable because of one
question to all three of you will start
with cucumber and we'll go around the
horn what's the most unexpected roll or
unexpected uncanny quality that a lot of
people don't realize about your
particular Chris we all know about the
chisel jaws and the and there and there
are great swashbuckling starring roles
but what's the most unexpected quality
or role from your particular Chris
cucumber good I think that would be the
way that he tends to he beautifully and
artfully in interrupts his own sentences
it's it's
it's a beautiful gift that some people
can do and some people absolutely cannot
and he has a way of you can see the
entire process is going on in his head
anytime he delivers a line like that
when he's a little nervous or in over
his head or something like that he goes
through about 16 emotions at any given
time and I love watching him for it
lovely thank you cucumber Joestar you
know when they did the wet hot American
summer series on Netflix he's easily
he's the biggest name on that series
okay and it can easily just be a gag
that you brought someone in famous to do
your like silly comedy series but at no
point did he like wink at the camera he
put on that ridiculous seventies rocker
wig
and fell so far into the weird character
of this isolated legendary musician that
lives on the campgrounds that I actually
didn't know as Chris Pine for like a few
episodes he he just he just sunk into it
and again like it never felt like oh man
isn't it cool that Chris Pine did like a
walk-on on this he just gives just a
hundred and ten percent whether it's a
small role or or a larger role like Kirk
and by the way speaking 110 percent he
deserves that 110 percent worth of pay
paramount pony up and pay the man all
right paid Chris Pine a little plea from
Joe star there at the end Erica Ishii
when Chris Hemsworth appeared in the
OVAs Darryl The Roommate YouTube short
that Tyco ytg and Marvel put out before
Thor 3 I think it completely changed the
trajectory of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
just the way that he the writing in it
was so snappy and he really pulled it
off just this just being weird and silly
and sort of self itself referential and
and I think it loosened everything up
because things are getting so serious in
the Marvel Universe in I think everybody
was taking this also seriously even in
guardians of the galaxy I I think that
it the the tone can can be a little over
the place in terms of whether they
wanted to be a comedy and poking fun at
the Marvel Cinematic Universe or taken
seriously but I think they just went all
the way
with that short and it's it's a
remarkable if you haven't seen it please
go watch it on YouTube alright time
let's call it there wow what a
first-round matchup Chris's were flying
everywhere Dan Merle fact I mean I don't
really it's all it's all opinion based I
don't really have any factual things to
argue beyond the exclusion of Chris
Evans which many people should be very
very upset about I realize it is a
three-person game there was going to be
a Chris left out however they seem to be
some very strong feelings that Evans was
the Chris Noth selected to be argued in
this round Bucky is very sad today
America America Sarah and Rob alright so
going off the arguments and everything
Wow I mean I thought we laid out some
just some fun and thoughtful arguments
about their bodies of work about the
different qualities that each brings to
their role and Erica I I have not seen
Daryl the roommate I need I need to I
need to I need to see it I need to see
it ASAP like I need to see it like
yesterday and cucumber I I love that you
relate to the everyman but I I feel like
you just didn't have enough different
qualities around your Chris I thought it
almost of it came back to like the least
threatening guy and the guy you'd want
to like have a drink with the everyman
and we uh we hit that a lot so it didn't
really set him apart for me it came down
to Joe and Erica and I felt like just
Joe had the more specific different
flavors kind of like walked through that
much more of his filmography so for me
it was Joe that laid it out for Pine
it's fine time for me with Joe dan yes I
think it came down to we all know that
they're very likable we all know they've
been in a lot of good movies it came
down to the detail work I felt like
cucumber struggled a little bit on on
Pratt it was
just he's nice and he speaks well it's
just - but I need it a little bit more
and so it also for me came down between
Joe and Erica and and I feel like Joe
made the most compelling case for Chris
Pine even though he would not be my
personal choice for best Hollywood Chris
that would be Erica's choice I have to
go with Joe all right Joe star gets the
point
Danielle Radford tell us about the pole
for the bank is at a point buddy you
know uh the audience agreed chris pine
was at 47% chris pratt's was 23 and then
Hemsworth with 28% some other
suggestions for possible non Evans's
Chris's Chris Farley Christopher Reeves
mm-hmm and Chris Rock were some other
Chris's that were bandied about
Christopher Walken got a lot but I think
they're just trying to make somebody do
the impersonation and I'm sorry guys I'm
not doing it yeah well I want to do the
Christopher Walken cucumber do you ever
walk you cumber you never cease to
tickle me you mention hell or high water
the the wonderful woman who played the
the waitress in hell or high water just
passed away this week and I know she was
such a scene stealer so rest in peace
her her name is uh Margaret Bowman
Margaret Bowman yeah she was delightful
in that movie so uh we had a big
argument that she should have been
nominated for an Academy Award yeah I
know Dan Murrow I love Sumari I love the
charts for her to be given a
and our if we pick the Oscars a
nomination because she was still memory
yeah her sass she stole that scene so
hard okay it is 100 star cucumber and
Erica you have to get on the board
question numero dos crazy rich Asians
hits theaters this week go see it yeah I
see it
it's a rom-com so because of that we're
asking what's the best romantic comedy
of all time Wow
all right and we'll start with a player
number two
Joe star let's do it greatest best best
romantic comedy of all time it's uh it's
been here met Sally it's the best one
it's it's objectively the best rom-com
it's uh it's the one that they based all
the other rom-coms on it brought all the
tropes up to the modern age it's the one
everybody still talks about when they
talk about rom-coms it's look Billy
Crystal and meg Ryan set and and Rob
Reider as an Noor Efron as a quartet of
creators set such a huge standard with
When Harry Met Sally I it's very rare
that a movie comes along and establishes
the tropes of its genre that's strongly
from you know character arcs to New York
being important to just the banter that
the timing the rhythm how they should
feel you come out of a rom-com
and when you're like that was a good
romantic comedy or when you see moving
you're like this feels like a romantic
comedy what you're saying is this felt
like When Harry Met Sally so it's it's
the greatest it's the goat all right
thank you Joe star When Harry Met Sally
erica is she Amelie not only what is was
it a fantastic romantic comedy because
it has a lot of the hallmarks of
romantic comedy you know a couple that
that falls in love and finally gets
together at the end but he was an
incredible film like beautiful the score
was amazing it just it it was it was
just a stunning film and you know was up
for the Oscars which is not common for
romantic comedies and one thing I love
about Amelie is that
is choose sort of the tropes of romantic
comedies it's not about people like miss
communicating with each other it's about
two people just doing what they love and
finding each other and making everybody
else around them have better lives in
the process of that and it's it's about
lonely people finding each other and
that is such a big mood big mood Amelie
Thank You Erica
cucumber what you got I got the Princess
Bride it is a classic and the entire
thing is built around true love and its
power what's great about it though is
that it's funny its snarky its
self-aware its satirical even of
romantic comedies yet somehow by the end
of it your fall in love with all these
characters and everything that they give
you is real and you feel it despite the
silliness and despite the the camp I
think they do a great job all right
three very different answers best
rom-com fight it out I would like to say
something about Princess Bride
it is like one of my very favorite films
of all time and I have a poster of it
that being said I even have to admit to
myself that is deeply flawed and that
Buttercup does nothing she is a prop a
victim in it at the end like in romantic
comedies you like to imagine yourself in
there you're like oh I want to find that
love everybody wants to have a Wesley
but who wants to be like you know
fending off the advances of a prince
that wants to rape you and then feel
like the only way out of it is suicide
that happens in the movie Wow okay oh my
god this is part of the fight but I do
feel like that movies almost like
stripes sometimes or you're like I
remember the first half of that very
silly movie and then you watch the
second half you're like oh [ __ ]
but piggybacking off of off of that that
female lead I think that is a really
important part of a romantic comedy is
especially for women that really love
this genre is looking at that female
lead and just wanting to be her
and meg Ryan sets the standard in When
Harry Met Sally it's why she was in
sleeplessness why she was in you got
nails why she was in IQ a good rom-com
sets up a like a successful rom-com
basically sets up a movie factory for
its female starred they did it with
Sandra Bullock and that one just gave
just fed meg Ryan work because her
performance in that movie was so strong
that women were just like I just want to
keep seeing this once a year until I die
cucumber and he's no no response for the
dark tones of Princess Bride best fairy
tales have dark tones I think that the
every Brothers Grimm book you've ever
read that hasn't been busines fied to
hell it is dark by nature it is to scare
you out of these situations and all of
that as far as Buttercup suicide and all
that yeah it is flood it is flood it's
not perfect however everyone in it the
movie gives you so much more than just
these two people and a bunch of like you
know styrofoam actors around them every
person's story in those in that movie is
interesting and it's engaging it's
really really funny absolutely everybody
except for Buttercup who is part of the
romance
unfortunately whereas with Amelie
everybody around her you get the
individual stories of every person and
the things that make them really happy
and she does things to further that and
and he also you know has has these these
quirky attributes and that that just
make the world more interesting and
better around him as for a heroine Harry
Met Sally I mean Woody Allen already did
New York as sort of the center of
romantic comedy and that's not new in
when Harry might know it's not new it's
just an important element of a romantic
comedy and like I'd say Woody Allen
establish that earlier and as it is full
of tropes and one thing that I don't
care about in for one thing I don't care
for in romantic comedies is that it is a
lot about miscommunication and couples
denying feelings and not being open with
each other and that is it's just very I
think harmful as a trope in film in
general I mean that's a real thing I
mean yeah it's a trope and yeah this
movie is full of tropes but it created
them like it cemented them that's it's
like
going back and reading the first one in
modern Hollywood absolutely it's like
going back and reading princess of Mars
and being like this rips off Star Wars
it just doesn't work out I'm gonna use
your argument against Princess Bride
with buttercup because the dude I don't
know the dude's name in anomaly I can't
remember but yeah he does some things
and she sure loves him but it's it's
it's more about her just weird obsession
with this guy she really likes this idea
of this guy and it's more about her her
sort of weird quest almost to discover
to discover her own meet-cute in a way
it's like that's her Holy Grail is this
meat meat cute whereas I think when
Harry Met Sally is is a really really
good balance between these two
characters you see their arcs you see
how much depth both of them have you see
how they change over the years and I
don't know if I have to play the card
yet but the deli scene man
I'll have what she's having it's that's
that's the rom-com scene like people
still quote it people still know what
you're talking about when you do you're
like oh hell but she's having that's
that's the scene during court ability I
think I got you there but Princess Bride
and I feel like that's the only thing
that people know about that film they
don't necessarily know about any of the
other characters or really much of the
plot except that oh I guess I'll have
what she's having know I'll disagree
there you've had there's a fantastic
ensemble cast in Princess Bride and
there sure are a lot of people near
Amelie but I'll say in terms of
important tropes for what makes a
romantic comedy movie that best friend
that best friend and Carrie Fisher is
that best friend trope she's like she's
the standard-bearer she set she set the
tone for that character she knocks it
out of the park Carrie Fisher is
absolutely incredible in When Harry Met
Sally so it's not you know it's not just
a Billy Crystal meg Ryan thing there is
a really strong ensemble around them
sort of supporting that romantic sure I
feel like a lot of the tropes and
romantic comedies are lazy and it's set
up the laziness of
the tropes I feel like we don't have to
be bound by the tradition of romantic
comedies about like people not being
able to talk to each other or you know
and and like commonly proves that I
think if I was arguing you've got mail
you could hit me you could ding me on
the tiredness of rom-com tropes but I'm
not like I'm arguing like the the god
daddy of them all the guy daddy of all
broken flawed tropes yeah cucumber we
haven't heard a ton from you do you want
to chime in with some more points about
Princess Bride sure it's got everything
and again as a theme of true love right
the whole point is all of them are
helping these two get back together
and they all have their own missions as
well but when it comes down to it their
ultimate goal is to get Buttercup and
Wesley back together for their own
happiness and they all find their
happiness along the way everybody wins
except for you know Cameron because he's
a monster
it's got everything it's got so much art
and then even if you zoom out it's all
about you know family and learning to to
bridge those generations between the
grandfather and the grandson were
actually reading the story the entire
thing is a giant warm hug but it's done
tongue-in-cheek with with a lot of love
and I think that's important not just
romantic love all the love thank you
cucumber I by the way I enjoy your
namesake on salads let's go to final
thoughts here thank you Joe
why don't you start us start off give us
here our final thoughts Sleepless in
Seattle
I think cemented writer he had already
done this is the movie he was preparing
to do while he did Princess Bride this I
think really cemented Nora Ephron is the
go-to for for writers in this genre it
made Meg Ryan's career yeah we wouldn't
have the Meg yeah no absolutely
[Laughter]
you know I
the score is great Harry Connick jr. won
a Grammy for for the score it's it's
actually a really really fantastic
soundtrack I think there's just
something really amazing about just the
pace of this movie the snap the banter
it that feels like a well-written play
at times like there's just a very
specific style you know like you know in
the same way that like you hear a Kevin
Smith movie and you're like I didn't
have to know that was Kevin Smith movie
like I know that those are Kevin Smith
characters talking like those are Nora
Ephron characters talking and I love the
overall just theme of this movie because
the the back-and-forth throughout the
theme of When Harry Met Sally is is the
what seems to be a very shallow like
can-can fred kind of man and woman
befriends without wanting to have sex
with each other which if you know as the
movie kicks off is sort of shallow
seeming and I think by design because
then the the arc of that is that being
partners and being friends and soulmates
don't have to be mutually exclusive
things they're they're one in the same
and I think that that is where Harry
eventually gets on New Year's when he
sort of eventually finally professes his
love thank you Joe
Erika we final all right now actually
having a discussion in twitch to the
idea that men and women can't be friends
so you know Phil whenever we have sex
with each other
which is why you know it's a problem and
I think that romantic comedies like When
Harry Met Sally feed into that notion
Amelie is wonderful it's such an
incredible well-rounded film and the
romance in it is out of all of these
films one that I personally and I think
a lot of people would want it's about
overcoming your loneliness and finding
someone who has the same sort of broken
qualities as you and being better
together because of them it's about a
hudley relationship
about and and about making everybody
around you have better lives in the
process
Thank You Erica cucumber yeah final
thoughts I think that William Goldman's
script is timeless I think you can go
back and watch that movie in 30 or 40
years and it'll still ring true the same
way that it does now to people I believe
that Rob Reiner is one of the gemstones
of his career I think everybody inside
of it is it's just freaking perfect
everyone who's in it is at their very
very best and as far as you know it
being a healthy relationship I think
this was that as well these were two
people who absolutely loved each other
and it was them maintaining that even
though they were separated it was them
finding each other again and and and
finding that happy ending I think that
was great
all that faithfulness right the whole
monologue about it Thanks cucumber all
right
their time that is oh wow three very
different movies three really different
yeah uh Dan Merle facts and want to go
ahead and tell us your thoughts on this
argument well there's there's a factual
thing that and that and that that I feel
sort of hurt I was I was on the
borderline here there's a factual thing
that I think was sort of hurt Joe's case
what he was that in the beginning his
closing argument he referred to the
wrong film it was also similar to his
film which is that he said that
Sleepless in Seattle was the movie that
Rob Reiner was preparing what he was
doing Princess Bride Harry about Sally
but that also in my head sort of tied
into like I I felt that Joe's are you it
was just a little too much tied to just
the concept of established established
established and I think there's more to
it than that I think there's more than
just like you define this and define
that's certainly an element but in
totality I think I felt a little more
swayed by cucumber it was very difficult
cuz everybody made very good cases and
they're they're vol three very different
movies by looking at looking at the
three of them I think the one that I had
to go with was cucumber and a very
difficult match very difficult decision
to make for me yeah this was a
hard one for me to break down so it's
one vote for cucumber yeah I thought Joe
laid out all so many strong points but I
thought um Erica had a really strong
knock against that when she mentioned
Woody Allen and I'm thinking you know
Woody Allen like him aside but his movie
Annie Hall is such a classic rom-com
that has so many of those traits a
little disappointed that no one brought
up like bringing a baby or any Tracy and
Hepburn and stuff because it's not like
romantic comedies were invented in the
80s or anything like they've been around
but I thought that was such that that
would took a lot of the air out of Joe's
argument Joe still laid out so many
great points but I thought Joe also
helped her Erica's caused a little bit
by saying that the Holy Grail is the
meet-cute and I and when I think about
that in like what is that what is wrong
with that in a romantic comedy that
moment and I was actually swayed that
much more by Erica's argument cucumber
you know I thought you had some nice
points in there as well but I have to go
Erica with Amelie so we're tied cucumber
and Erica
Danielle sorry and my internet is not
being super great today it just conked
down on me so I am going to yeah I think
I just got it I've been like kind of
fighting with it the entire show I will
say one good meme that I did see or a
good tweet is a Sarah Wendling wrote if
someone doesn't immediately make a
Photoshop crossover of the Meg and make
royal
I definitely agree and so for the poll
Wow the poll is tied 41% for When Harry
Met Sally and 41% for Princess Bride I'm
not kidding
sandy percent prominently okay it's this
isn't update this is the update this
isn't update this is the latest latest
okay so the latest latest going awesome
dance whoo-hoo refreshed his a couple of
seconds after I refreshed mine it is
princess bride at 42% and when Harry Met
Sally at 39 HS bride takes it yeah that
was miss Redford
were there other answers besides meg
Ryan and Meg to some people put in how
to marry a millionaire of course pretty
woman a lot of people with the Twilight
Saga coming in strong I don't know if
that super counts but that's okay we you
find love the way you need it I mean I
don't know if there's is there comedy I
mean I was really got a lot of votes for
that as per always someone said the room
because they like me lala land someone
mentioned which is not obviously I mean
that's musical but I again find your
love where you can get it y'all all
right there you go
and Danielle give me a heads up if
anyone creates a dank meme of meg Ryan
as the Meg please y'all we need this so
bad
[Music]
all right so we are tied up 1/4 cucumber
1/4 Joestar Erica is she yet to get on
the board question numero tres infinity
war hits blue rays this Tuesday and now
you can relive the snap over and over so
much as you want
what movie character host deserves to be
Thanos snapped out of existence
what movie character needs to not feel
so well all right and it's question
number three well start with the player
number three
Erica Ishii so I chose mr. Yunioshi as
played by Mickey Rooney in Breakfast at
Tiffany's there is so much that we love
and remember from Breakfast at Tiffany's
Audrey Hepburn's lovely performance the
iconic her iconic look Moon River was
fantastic and that that's a great sort
of entry into the romantic comedy we
tend to forget about is the like worse
than World War 2 era racist yellow face
in the movie which is like so it's it's
just real real bad so everything else
about that film and that could be a
great classic film except for that one
little elements with a remove that one
problematic element we can all put up
those posters of Holly Golightly in
peace and cuz honestly honestly I love
that I love that song and I we I have a
dear friend who has a Holly Golightly
tattoo on her back but every time I look
at that and like there's yellow face
really bad yellow face in that film and
I I don't know if we just got rid of it
I think it would be a much better film
Erica thank you for your answer mr.
Yunioshi from breakfast at tiffany's
cucumber what you got I am a jar jar
binks
this is not an attack on I'm at best
that sir did a good job I mean just as a
character he is just absolute garbage
everything he says actually about 90% of
what he said oh god I know a lot of what
he says him on his own saying random
crap to nobody at all just like their
wiggling around just in the background
or in the foreground or doing whatever
just there's no reason for him to exist
at all except for you know he's there to
make things more difficult for them but
at the same time it could have been done
by tripping over a trash can and the
movie would've been the same you
could've actually focused on on the plot
of episode 1 what little there was
alright Jar Jar is cucumbers choice Joe
um well first of all I just want to
address I love you so much and you put
me in an interesting position where I
have to argue that intellectually and in
theory I agree with you we still have to
do a show tell me about Harry Potter Joe
yeah that's why I'm arguing Severus
Snape this crazy-ass creepy bastard
look at him yeah yeah you know what he's
looking at right now
pictures of Harry's dead mom
[Applause]
creeper severus snape sucks man this
here okay this is a guy who bought into
the friendzone trope where he's like oh
no she won't why won't she have sex with
me why does she like James Potter
because I have a bad Alan Rickman
impression oh no and then he never moves
on and let's go and just obsesses with
this lady forever he just obsesses with
her and then transferred not only is
after they after they die does he let it
go mm-hmm he just keeps taking it out on
this little ten-year-old boy it's awful
and then at the finally at the end of
his arc Oh guys guys
Snape's the hero because he stayed
obsessed with this lady wouldn't get out
of her life for years took it out on the
ghetto but he's he's the hero that's
such a gross message to send to kids in
a children's book that this weird greasy
wizard John Cusack that would come home
box down well past this lady's death is
a hero and so I would snap that guy
right out of existence her mind he's got
it covered they don't need snakes all
right Joe Stark goes shotsfired a whole
harry potter verse fight it out
everybody disagree uh without Severus
Snape Harry would have died in what book
1 Oh
counter-curse is the only person paying
attention and then later on when my when
is when his legs all injured because he
went to go and try and stop somebody
from stealing that stone from underneath
fluffy you know that Judas but he was
picking up so much hurt once he gets
sent to the nurse and she's like bone of
fixham MIOSHA and he's fine over
inflating snake he is actually essential
to I I agree you just need to let things
go so after a while but he is absolutely
essential to the plot because he stopped
the curse of the spread of the curse of
the gaunt ring Dumbledore would have
died within the year and like we he
wouldn't have been able to help Harry
get the locket wizards list he recalled
for potions kills dumbledor to save
Draco's life Draco is also crappy but he
is a kid he would have been forced to
kill Dumbledore and then also he
provided Harry with all the information
that he needed to defeat DUP and
Voldemort at the end he's absolutely
essential to the plot so you can't just
gonna snap him out of existence guy has
sad [ __ ] tears once and he's a hero I'll
take everything need to be a hero to be
essential to a plot and into to be
something and as we wanted in this age
being a hero is very complicated
business I just don't think the dudes
essential there are so many talented
wizards and witches around young Harry
Potter who would have easily escorted
him through this quest double agent
special of him off of the Quidditch
pitch cucumber tell me why Jar Jar is
not just the best choice but
specifically a better choice than Snape
and mr. Yunioshi from Breakfast at
Tiffany's
I'm in it to win it well okay so mr.
Yunioshi I would say he's necessary to
see how far we've come Horace my choice
Snape again I will unlike Snape Jar Jar
is not really central to any plot he is
one vote and that vote could have been
swung in the direction of any other
alien that is in that Senate beyond that
he is just noise he was comic relief but
he wasn't the right kind he was like he
was like a Looney tune and a silly
symphony like he was still funny but
he's in a different world somewhere I I
would say that Jar Jar is kind of the
easy choice but unlike Breakfast at
Tiffany's which has merits outside of
this one character that can just be
gotten rid of you can't also finger snap
away awkward writing and a over long
podracing that can't well but that's the
things that these fingers snap Jar Jar
Binks out of existence like what is left
still nothing here's what happens if you
if you get rid of Jar Jar Binks was a
lot of things he was also a mocap
achievement and I think if you snap Jar
Jar Binks that episode one where's Andy
Serkis gonna come in you lose all that I
think I think there's a there's a chain
of events there there's a there's a
chaos there's a full goldblum chaos
theory that happens if you lose Jar Jar
Binks and that means you lose golem and
you lose you lose all of the fans of
anti circuses work you lose that great
viral video of a Benedict Cumberbatch
being smile Gauri's in the little suit
he's gonna like where
fun video that's great let's get some
final thoughts from everybody Erica lay
it down any film with black face like a
classically breakfast as Tiffany's is
still considered like a classic film
people like as I said there are girls
with tattoos and on them and like it's
an every every caste sorority girls like
college dorm on the wall and everything
and that's great it's there it could be
forgivable yes if he wasn't in it if we
could just snap him out of existence
Thank You Erica cucumber and then move
on you know yeah maybe maybe everyone
else wouldn't have seemed so bad with
him around enhancing or dancing
everything that he was in he's just not
necessary
all right thank you cucumber Joestar and
I know everyone's just gonna be like
awed Joe's making a joke answer but this
is something I think about a lot just
the weird gross John Cusack character
tropes that I think poisoned a
generation of men and you know the I you
know the I'm staying outside the the the
place are like Rob Gordon my fidelity
rise and I think that uh you know these
are not good people and they're not
they're not monsters they're not
villains but there's a there's like a
weird dangerous precedent that they set
when you watch those movies that you're
like that guy's a hero that guy is that
guys are romantic and you see it in
things like that weird viral video or
that article that went viral about oh
this guy's gonna play the piano in the
park every day until this lady like
loves him again like that stuff's not
good and I think Snape represents that
idea in Harry Potter and I think that
that's a bad lesson for kids to learn
Jar Jar sucks but I don't know man we've
had a lot of laughs as a result
and as as far as breakfast at tiffany's
goes Erika said two things in this
argument that really stuck with me and
they were both the same sentence it was
leave it up there which when Looney
Tunes started airing regularly again
they made a decision to have Whoopi
Goldberg do intros for some of the more
questionable shitty stuff and I really
love this quote these depictions were
wrong then and they are wrong today
editing them would be the same as
denying that the stereotypes existed I
do think that it's important to look
back and see how far we've come if at
all in how shitty we've been you really
need to leave it up there and Snape
needs to wash his hair your greasy
bastard you crazy gross bastard time all
right there you have it Wow
three three very divergent different
arguments here Dan what do we have
factually there's a point at which this
chat over here on Daniel screen I'll
glance over there sometimes it's usually
moving at a pretty good clip yeah when
the video feed caught up to Joe's answer
it looked like I was watching the matrix
in Danielle's Internet yeah it just
keeps going Wow that notwithstanding Joe
was almost immediately out of this
argument for me from from from cucumbers
and Eric oohs they just brutalized the
necessity of that character into the
narrative and the story and that and
that entire saga so Joe I'm sorry you
were you were almost immediately
eliminated spare from that round there's
a nice cup mounting a counter defense at
the end there but it was between for me
cucumber and Erica Andrea here's an
Erica did she catch sheet she did
something that I call she Kevin Smith
this round in the sense that if you if
you'll remember a couple of years ago I
I fought Kevin Smith at a live movie
fight and he came up with an answer to a
question that was so incontrovertible
that even attempting to exercise it was
like what movies should be banished from
existence and I was like jaws toukas
sequels suck in the lighter woods it's
something else and chemicals is like
triumph of the will however it wasn't
just the answer though it was the fact
that I thought Erika made a very good
case about the fact that the rest of the
movie is very well regarded really glad
it was considered to be a classic that
it has great performances that it's a
well-loved movie and that if you were to
take that character out of the movie it
would allow the rest of the film to
shine and I thought that was a great
argument and that's why I'm going with
Erika thank you Dan yes so it's one for
Erika my thoughts are starting to
trickle down similarly to yours I will
say and just yeah Joe we're gonna have
to disembowel the entire series I get
your point though and you made a great
point about just like carrying a torch
and how we kind of hold that aloft or
give credence to that in Soma so many of
our endeavors so that it even though I
think Snape is a terrible choice you had
some really wonderful thoughts on that
whole trope there was a you got me to
actually listen and I appreciate it
really hard not to recycle your material
from the old Harry Potter and I thought
we also had some interesting points in
regards to the if we took Jar Jar out of
Episode one then we'd still have other
things that were troubling for the film
and also no one brought up this point
but I think a Jar Jar he's serving a
comedic relief he's doing that service
for the film which Star Wars films have
comic relief in them this one was just
not very successful but yeah at the end
of the day I have to go with Erik
for much of what dan laid out and yeah
Danielle
cucumber high-five incoming so yeah for
the the pole the pole overwhelmingly 57%
for mr. Yunioshi yeah um wait George are
at 30 and Snape at 11%
Thank You 11 I appreciate you
any other any other choices yeah fingers
snapped out of existence Jack Shipley
sent what it appears to be at the wisdom
that dude in one of any of the movies he
was in I don't remember with what dude
what this is the Mickey Rooney no no no
no no no hamburger helper glove I'm sure
I in any of the movies I can't tell if
this is biodome or what are the other
ones
I mean he's essential to in the army now
case you can probably go and then Andrew
J know sent us mutt Williams Goodwin
Shia LaBeouf and crystal skull by
LaBeouf yeah by an above but this is
left with a whole movie aboard Harrison
Ford on the scene mr. Jones I don't feel
so good this is a great moment in sports
we're all tied up 1 1 1 so it was time
for that tiebreaker okay so it works
kind of like the speed round or almost
exactly like the speed round except this
time with three players so I will ask
the question the players will give their
answer and they will each have 20
seconds to argue their answer and Oh is
there a 10 second rebuttal on this help
me out yes yes and then 10 second
rebuttals and then we will pick the one
who will not move on we'll pick the one
okay answer it goes false third okay so
and the order you will be able to argue
your answer is the order we hear you so
just shout out your answer once you hear
the question here is the tiebreaker
what comic book movie that wasn't rated
R should have been
comic book movie not rated R but should
have been Dick Tracy okay
Dick Tracy Erica and cucumber we need an
answer phantom the Phantom with Billy
Zane fans bomb yo okay Billy Zane's the
phantom thinking of Ben Affleck being
the Bob in Phantom oh you're right nods
or is it it was Watchmen was our alright
and there was also an owl in there watch
[Applause]
V for Vendetta
thank you house keys are really on top
of things god I guess I guess the first
the first x-men okay
alright the first x-men alright so we
heard Dick Tracy first then we heard
phantom then we heard first x-men so Joe
20 seconds begin whenever you speak
Dick Tracy is already an exercise in
insanity it's this all-star cast doing a
comic book movie about this weird old
Sunday comic they're all playing these
crazy big over-the-top characters if
this movie have been our and there had
just been blood and hardcore actual
detective noir violence and bad language
it would have been propelled into just a
legendary status instead of just sort of
a silly curiosity all right cucumber 20
seconds for the Phantom all right I
still have nightmares to this day of a
particular scene in that movie which
involved a Jud fry style a microscope so
it's like the switchblade from Oklahoma
except it was a microscope so you'd like
lean in and then you turn a little
knobby knob and then
blade go straight through your eyeball
into your skull and that that messes you
up as a kid man that's it still got a
little time all right there you go
switchblade microscope Erica
when we all saw Logan we realized that
Wolverine and any film that he was in
should have been rated R from the start
he's not a character that is meant to be
in a pg-13 film I think that it would
have elevated the first film and would
have given them more license to be
darker and and granted it was a little
ahead of its time and ahead of the curve
all right 10 second rebuttals Joestar I
think r-rated x-men would have just made
it even more of a Wolverine film and
push the other characters even more to
the side I think that you that
microscope is already scary enough at
pg-13 and again r-rated Dick Tracy
cucumber 10 second rebuttal
Dick Tracy is in you know it's its
product of that comic-book time
especially you know all that blood would
have just kind of ruined all the beauty
that they were putting into the
production design of that film it would
have over washed over it as for
Wolverine and the first x-men gang it
mm-hmm
Erica ishi blood wouldn't have helped a
Dick Tracy film the best noir films
they're not rated R they don't need
blood to be frightening or to set the
tone that's what new art is also that
microscope sounds scary already all
right by the way my old improv team was
named switchblade microscope
Danielle RAD my favorite and your
radford give us your thoughts
no no poles no poles now no time
actually I have to vote for myself these
were some really good arguments
considering how it felt like y'all we're
struggling to kind of find the words for
this I have to say the one that I found
most compelling even though oh so let's
pick the one that will not move on oh
yeah yeah but if you want to give your
rank at whatever yeah yes so the one
that I found like the most compelling
was I
I appreciated cucumbers argument about
how that would have ruined the design
and then I thought that Joe had a great
argument about how an r-rated x-men
would have pushed the other characters
to the side I have to say the one that
doesn't go on as Erica Ishii as much as
it kills me
all right Thank You Danielle Dan Merle
straight forward for me I felt that
counter arguments are not enough and
cucumber did not really make an argument
for why his movie he described the scene
that was already in the movie but he
never made a compelling argument as to
why his movie should have been rated R
so I will my vote would be to advance Jo
and Erica and the cucumber would not
move on and so we have a vote for Erica
a vote for cucumber not to move on and I
am going to yeah I think dan Merle kind
of said it for me
cucumber described a like a violent
scene that was already in the movie but
did not make the case for it being are
also Joe the movie you described making
Dick Tracy an art was called Sin City
Sin City all right
the speed round is set Joestar Erica
Ishii cucumber
I hope you can bring the heat a little
bit hotter next time when the belt is on
the line a little bit harder when you go
pass one round my ex movie fights
champion Anne Burrell tastes like
cucumber okay we're in the speed round
best of luck to everyone you guys know
how it works it'll works just like the
thing I just did does okay
cucumber yeah you're a fine felted
friend question number one steven
spielberg's hook is getting a 4k home
video release with 11 deleted scenes
better nostalgic 1991 movie hook or The
Rocketeer Rocketeer hook yeah that's
what's the one left okay so Joe has The
Rocketeer erica has hook Joe 20 seconds
begins whenever you speak nothing you
loved about hook as a kid holds up now
it is a garbage movie easily Steven
Spielberg's worse it's all these weird
ideas just it's sad and depressing that
lost boys are depressed the Pirates are
depressed everything about it is just
sad and broken nothing about it is
joyful like you remember The Rocketeer
is the Moot is the Captain America movie
that you had been waiting years and
years for it's just emotes this feeling
of The Greatest Generation
Erica hook is very much something that
we need right now yeah it's about
finding that joy that you felt when you
were a child it's something that I think
would make the world a better place if
it were to come out and be popularized
today it absolutely holds up bearing
also The Rocketeer is he's it's like if
we had Captain America but Captain
America was not here that 10 second
rebuttals the nostalgia fixture looking
for it does not exist in hook and a fun
word does not that nostalgia trip make
but nothing beats just that scene where
the mob and the FBI work together to
fight the Nazis and Rocketeer come on
dude
Erica ten seconds we go when you speak I
don't know if you've seen Rocketeer
lately but I have and I think the reason
that people would want to see it is also
for nostalgic reasons but it's not even
remembered as fondly as hook is hook has
a time all right
Wow 1991 what a year for nostalgia just
going on both those answers I think Joe
just landed more specific points and
kind of set Erica back on her heels
defending her film so my vote is for Joe
Danielle it's my favorite fish don't
come here yeah I do have to agree with
that I do think that Joe had very very
specific arguments and I love Erica but
she definitely gave up in that last
rebuttal and as soon as you kind of give
up you kind of give up the round for me
so I gotta go with Joe all right Joe
takes it it is two-one Joe and again the
first player to four is our Victor
question number two Elizabeth Banks will
star in a movie about a woman who won a
date with a with prince who what not
with a prince with Prince what movie
featuring Prince songs should be remade
Purple Rain or the 1989 Batman Batman
alright okay we have Tim Burton's 99
Batman versus Purple Rain Joe you spoke
first so you go first 20 seconds weekend
when you speak I mean the real reason
you remake the 89 Batman in this case is
you don't touch Purple Rain now what are
you gonna do the man is gone is to send
it to a higher plane of existence and
you would just be destroying Purple Rain
whereas you can redo the 89 Batman and
it'll be fine where does that guy get
his wonderful toys it's a parade you
could redo the bat dance sure that's not
that's not like and a hugely important
song to Prince
they keep constantly making and remaking
Batman films I think that the American
public has had enough of it
we don't need to see another another
Joker film honestly I and we are getting
one anyway we don't need to remake
literally the same one that has already
happened as for Purple Rain I think that
we can do it with a fresh new twist and
we can be completely different I will
drown myself in the waters of Lake
Minnetonka before I let you ruin that
movie I will watch 17 more Jared Leto
Joker movies and I think America would
rather do that then touch the the Bible
that is Purple Rain
gotta go start the clock what if we made
it with lin-manuel Miranda directing it
that's that's all that's all I have
it'll be great
time all right okay yeah we're gonna fix
that girl
yeah put on the list of things to see
Dan Merle whoo this is difficult the the
the rebuttal round I'll have to say did
not work in Erica's favor however I
thought that she laid out a pretty
devastating case against Jo and her
initial arguments and I don't know if he
overcame that case so even though the
counter-argument didn't really do a lot
it's it did enough for me to say I think
Erika took this for me yeah I'm gonna
agree with you Dan I think Jo laid out a
good case why Purple Rain it could
border on sacrilege to remake that but
Erika had a devastating blow against
Batman and also I was looking for
something around your tape because I was
thinking that I know it doesn't matter
but like when they when NBC remakes does
those musicals it's a fresh take on
things and lin-manuel Miranda bring him
into the mix might give us some kind of
palatable version so that was enough for
me to score the win on that point even
though it would it's gonna be tough to
remake Purple Rain
we got so many Batman's alright it's 2-2
question number three
ready or not child's play remake is
moving forward who should voice Chucky
in the new child's play voice of Chucky
Oh Josh GAD Josh Galli
oh my god alright Josh GAD and Keuka
Erica 20 seconds begin when you speak go
Josh GAD is making a name for himself in
voiceover right now he is extremely
talented he is as Broadway training but
you listen to Olaf the snowman and you
tell me that that's not a creepy voice
that would really be unsettling to hear
coming out of Chuckies mouth josh god I
think the world has already turned
against Josh GAD and we're already
creeped out by Olaf so we don't need to
see it again meanwhile there is a very
fresh bass performer who also has a kind
of a little bit of a chin nails on the
chalkboard voice that I would hear
coming right before it stabbed me I said
he's a great performer he could really
improvise using Chucky which i think is
important I'm a big fan of cucumber but
I don't know if he has the acting chops
right now honestly because I don't
believe exactly I only believe believe
in has a sweet and lovable felted
american new direction and maybe that
direction is a sweet young child and
that's the scary thing it's this young
child doll that looks like a child it's
gonna kill you it's a real my buddy not
a creepy very bad thing
Wow okay Josh GAD and cucumber
[Laughter]
okay
I speak hysterical I think that Joe made
a very good point about have we not
already been creeped out by Josh GAD and
do we not want that one it is three two
and this is game point for Joe cucumber
good luck I hope you can get even get in
the audition room or the audition voice
yes three - Joe Joe takes this it takes
the game Erica needs this tie it up
alright question um before the speed
round we saw a new promo photo this week
for the upcoming John wick three what
movie character should cross over and
through the into the John wick verse
what movie carriage should cross over
into the John wick first doesn't have to
be in an established film already or
it's a movie character what established
movie character yes and a character who
has already appeared in a movie should
appear in the John wick verse
the devil from Devil's Advocate is that
Al Pacino yeah
devil from Devil's Advocate starring
Keanu Reeves and Al Pacino yep hitman
from the agent 47 from the from the
Hitman films
agent 47 from the hitman films okay Joe
star we heard you first so go ahead
whenever you're feeling it we've seen
John wick fight hitmen we've seen him
fight a shitload of hitmen at least 750
hitmen you know we haven't seen him take
on the supernatural and who better it's
a good fit for the supernatural then Al
Pacino who could easily enter that world
as sort of the greasy businessman take
on the devil I think that could actually
be really cool gun foo versus just ALPA
Chino and his crazy eyes in a slick suit
and his zero morals because he's the
devil one thing that I've always loved
about the John wick films is the video
game sensibilities and you know even
though agent the agent 47 phones have
not been up to snuff so far and combined
with just the great directing team of
John wick and action sensibilities of
video game movies I think that we could
have something really interesting plus
as a story they'd be fighting together
ten-second rebuttals
I think there's something interesting
about an arc of John wick working for
this guy slowly realizing he's working
for and making choices as a result again
I think the devil as played by Al Pacino
fits in the same way as a hitman
character would it's very obvious that
they have both been learning from each
other both the new with the newest
hitman named and John wick and I think
that their tones are perfectly matched
up which is something that I don't think
could be said for Al Pacino time okay
I forgot to say twas a reunion for my
money I don't think you need to say I
feel like you laid out how Pacino would
fit in and add a different fun element
where I think and you noted it in your
initial argument Joe that Erica it
seemed like you were adding more of the
same to what the film already has and I
didn't see it enhancing the movie at all
so for that I'm going Joe star Dan Merle
I agreed that I think the tones are a
little too say me that we've seen it
before and I want to see Al Pacino
called John wick and I'm so for those
reasons I am going with Joe and doubles
advocate there you go Joe scholar
takes the day
nicely done JQ Joe well played you beat
the Felton friend and you beat our true
friend Erica go ahead and ya shout out
some stuff ears thank you for coming
cucumber if you guys haven't watched
perception check it's an amazing show
the cucumber and chunk do Mondays on
hyper RPG and you guys are fantastic I
love you and fell in love with this kid
at the tournament of nerds of which we
are celebrating the 10th anniversary of
this Saturday you know what Joe thank
you for bringing it up my brother Joe
Starr always doing funny crap at
tournament and nerds Erica is she has
blessed our stage many times and Erica
weird and I were just reminiscing about
the time she ran around the UCB theater
in Los Angeles with an unsheathed
samurai sword was also amazing and she
brings it every time and as to you sir
it always means a lot to be at the table
with you guys and to be on stage at that
show so I'm excited if you're in LA if
you're near LA come out and see us on
Saturday midnight UCB Franklin in LA the
10th anniversary show of the tournament
of nerds Thank You Erica you'll also be
there go ahead and plug anything else
you got going on yeah I'm so excited for
the tournament I've met some of my best
friends and collaborators there I'm on
Twitter at Erica Ishii on Instagram at
the Erica Ishii and let's see how you
can find me at geek and Sun on geek &
sundry I have a video game show if
you're interested in that sort of thing
4 p.m. on Tuesdays and I'm gonna be
starting at the stay tuned
Travis McElroy and Amy Dallen and I are
gonna be doing a little podcast soon
about it's called positivity knee and
it's like 10 minutes of positivity to
start your day
that sounds lovely Thank You Erica um
cucumber thank you so much for being
here you want some wonderful answers and
I'm sure you'll bring the a game when
the titles on the line next time please
go ahead and plug some stuff you guys Oh
certainly so you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and cucumber lips
but you can also follow our perception
check stuff at perception check D&D the
letters or PC D&D we're on hyper RPG on
Monday nights on our own twitch channel
on Wednesday nights and were playing all
kinds up about to start a firefly
campaign on hyper it's gonna be fun
we're reusing the bait system it's gonna
be a good time fun sponge cucumber dan
Morelle thank you for holding it down
brother belts I don't eat them BAM mic
drop damn bro thanks any anything else
to plug our ad um no what watch screens
watch screen junkies news and don't Joe
don't you have a relative running for
elected office
I know god I absolutely do are you tired
of business as usual and student council
high school politics I know I am and
that's why I'm supporting my cousin Ruby
for sergeant-at-arms at the name of her
high school I just forgot off the top of
my head Hill wood high school Hill wood
high school thank you so Ruby you've got
my support and you've got my vote as
soon as I figure out a way to disguise
myself as a high school student as long
as you promise pizza every day Joe don't
disguise yourself as a high school
student I really should but that's how
much I wanted to win yeah go Ruby go
Ruby I love it um Danielle Radford hi
hello I mean I just if you want to see
all of the various things I'm doing
follow me on twitter at daniel Radford
kissing shown at the love it deserves
[Laughter]
and yeah please follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at how Rudnick I've been
asking a lot of fun weird movie fight
questions on my Instagram I couldn't
believe it
the results I asked Sylvester Stallone
versus Arnold Schwarzenegger pick one
who do you prefer and it was an
overwhelming result go to my Instagram
or my Twitter to find that and yeah
having a lot of fun on there and we'll
talk about movies and whatnot I want to
thank you for watching I wanna thank
these guys for bringing it oh so hard
and I want to thank Billy biz Patterson
jte in the booth and the whole gang for
making this show happen see you next
time bye
you